excusez moi oui c'est votre voiture là
ouais ouais
la jaguar vous gagnez combien vous
seriez 1 72 mille dollars mois dernier
si vous montrer une fiche de paie avec
72 mille dessus je quitte mon job
ildiko et je bosse pour vous et hdmi
cian je vais bosser à la bourse
je m'appelle jordan belle fille tout
juste âgée de 22 ans je me suis dirigé
vers le sol en droit à la hauteur de mes
noble ambition la règle du jeu prendre
l'argent de la poche de ton client pour
le mettre dans la tienne mais si en plus
tu peux bien faire gagner c'est
profitable pour tout le monde pas vrai
non
[Musique]
j'ai démarré ma propre société dans un
garage abandonné nous ciblons le 1 % des
américains les plus riches
j'adore trois choses j'adore mon pays
que j'adore jésus et j'adore rendre les
gens riches à l'eau mais je devais les
façonner à mon image avec ce manuel
je vais apprendre à chacun d'entre vous
à devenir le meilleur
nous sommes la meilleure société au
monde
je devenais une légende et pas mariés et
les gens mariés ne peuvent pas avoir
d'amis on ne fera pas des amis
[Musique]
je me faisais tellement de fric je
savais plus confère 26 mille dollars
pour un dîner n'est plus pauvre papa dit
lui ce qu'on a commandé que c'est quoi
ces extras salle déry cancer oui c'est
guéri le cancer c'est ça le problème est
du coup c'est pour ça
la vraie question est est ce que tous
sachent qui est légal
où est le ballon
[Musique]
absolument pas il a des photos de tout
ton entourage
on est bien ici c'est le pays de toutes
les opportunités attention tentative de
corruption d'un agent fédéral fils et
l'amérique c'est chez moi
[Applaudissements]
pour mieux pour vous mon petit gars moi
votre quotidien le spectacle continue
ils vont être obligés d'envoyer la carte
nationale pour me déloger
pas pour toi mec que mon fric scotché
sûreté ni beurre alors techniquement c